[Música]
china ha vivido en los últimos días
varias jornadas de manifestaciones
ciudadanas en rechazo a esa política
gubernamental de cero covid si bien la
calma ya ha regresado algunas de las
ciudades chinas después de que
levantaron las fuertes medidas de
seguridad que comprendían despliegue de
la policía también el vallado de algunas
de las calles para impedir El Avance de
las manifestaciones el gobierno chino se
refirió al respecto a estas
manifestaciones y reafirmó las
libertades legales de los ciudadanos Tal
parece que allí es permitido protestar y
manifestarse en contra del gobierno por
lo menos así lo hacen ver en los
diferentes medios de comunicación
internacionales también se refirieron a
los periodistas extranjeros a raíz de la
detención del corresponsal de la bbc en
una de estas manifestaciones veamos
china es un país gobernado por el estado
de derecho y los diversos derechos y
libertades legales que disfrutan los
ciudadanos chinos están plenamente
garantizados de conformidad con la ley
al mismo tiempo todos los derechos y
libertades deben ejercerse dentro del
marco de la ley
los periodistas extranjeros tienen
derecho a informar sobre las noticias en
China de conformidad con la ley pero
también deben cumplir con las leyes y
reglamentos de China al cubrir historias
deben presentar sus tarjetas de prensa
con anticipación Y no deben participar
en actividades incompatibles con su
condición de periodistas
Esa es la perspectiva del gobierno chino
entre tanto algunos sectores de la
comunidad internacional se han mostrado
en rechazo por esta rigurosa política de
cero covid porque el mundo entero ya
está prácticamente abierto después de la
pandemia de Kobe 19 otros sectores de la
comunidad internacional se han mostrado
preocupados por estas represión que han
vivido los ciudadanos que han
participado en las protestas sobre este
tema se pronunció el portavoz del
secretario general de la ONU escuchemos
bueno no tengo ningún comentario en
particular sobre las políticas de covid
Pero obviamente hemos visto algunos de
los vídeos de manifestaciones y nuestras
reacciones la misma que tenemos para
todo el mundo es que creemos en la
importancia del derecho de las personas
a la reunión y asociación pacíficas su
derecho a manifestarse pacíficamente e
instalar las autoridades a garantizar
ese derecho
Bueno hay que decirlo es difícil el
cubrimiento de este tipo de temas para
los medios occidentales cuando tienen
lugar allí en China en redes sociales
Como por ejemplo Twitter que está
prohibida en ese país asiático algunos
usuarios aseguran que la policía ha
estado revisando los teléfonos de los
transeúntes para tomar los datos de
aquellos que están usando aplicaciones
que son vetadas en China y en las que
están publicando imágenes que dan
evidencia de la magnitud de las
protestas y también de las respuestas
que han dado las autoridades en las
diferentes regiones algunos de los
vídeos muestran Cómo manifestantes de
esa teoría que sea esparcido a lo largo
de ancho de China de que las
manifestaciones están siendo gestadas
desde el exterior del país y otros
aseguran que están allí por su propia
voluntad y por sus ganas de querer
manifestarse y así lo han dejado en
evidencia en algunos de sus vídeos y
publicaciones en redes sociales que no
están permitidas en ese país Mientras
tanto en occidente pues analizamos estas
manifestaciones con los recursos que
tenemos pero todo hay que decirlo los
medios chinos no hablan sobre este tema
veamos algunos de ellos cgtn en español
que es el canal internacional chino para
iberoamérica no mencionan su página web
del día de hoy por lo menos hasta el
momento en que este programa sea el aire
no menciona nada sobre este tipo de
manifestaciones vamos a cgtn en inglés
que es también la publicación en idioma
inglés tampoco menciona este tipo de
temas en la portada del día de hoy lo
repito hasta el momento hasta el momento
de salir esta emisión al aire aquí en
France 24
pasemos al portal people Daily que está
disponible en 15 idiomas diferentes
tampoco publica alguna información sobre
las manifestaciones o hace algún
recuento de los hechos del fin de semana
o por lo menos comentar algo sobre lo
sucedido el sábado del domingo en
ciudades importantes son las grandes
ciudades chinas china Daily también está
disponible en diferentes idiomas además
de el idioma chino no menciona este tema
por supuesto Todas están enfocadas en un
lanzamiento en un parte del programa
espacial chino y finalizamos con Beijing
news que es un portal netamente en chino
tampoco publica noticias sobre estas
manifestaciones
pero ojo las manifestaciones han pasado
a ser solamente contrarias a estas
medidas adoptadas para hacer frente a la
pandemia de Kobe 19 y ha llevado a que
haya brotes de ciudadanos en contra por
ejemplo del presidente y también del
partido comunista un desafío total
contra el sistema que expone a los
manifestantes a terminar en la cárcel de
acuerdo a las leyes de ese país como
entonces la sociedad china llegó a este
cúmulo de factores para llegar a este
descontento y salir a las calles a
demostrárselo y a decirle a las
autoridades que no están de acuerdo con
algunas de las medidas que ellos han
adoptado estas manifestaciones cómo
afectan al gobierno de China a nivel
internacional
veamos vemos un hartazgo general en
China vemos también un hartazgo general
en Irán por ejemplo que son países que
tienen regímenes muy rígidos y que son
criticados a nivel internacional por sus
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos Hay
algo aquí de coincidencia hay en común
entre este tipo de manifestaciones y
hartazgo Pese a que los orígenes son
distintos pero el Común denominador es
el hartazgo hacia los gobiernos es esto
entonces un punto de quiebre para el
gobierno Chino lo vamos a analizar esta
coyuntura en el debate de France 24 y
para conversar sobre este tema hemos
invitado a Margarita cadavid ella es
especialista en derechos humanos y
defensa ante sistemas de protección y
también está con nosotros Raquel León de
la Rosa ella es directora del
observatorio de política china ustedes
nuestros televidentes Recuerden que
ustedes también hacen parte de este
debate pueden dejar comentarios
preguntas sobre los temas que estamos
analizando lo pueden hacer A través de
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook en instagram nos encuentran
como arroba el
debate_f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo la etiqueta es
numeral el debate f24 no se olviden ya
para terminar esta introducción larga
introducción el día de hoy que todos los
contenidos están disponibles también en
Apple podcast en Spotify
la doy la bienvenida entonces a
Margarita aquí en el estudio de France
24 para conocer opiniones de lo que
sucede en China vamos a analizar la
situación y El Punto de partida
Margarita es que se conjugó en China
para llegar a este escenario a este
hartazgo de la sociedad para salir a la
calle a desafiar al gobierno comunista y
al mismo presidente Bueno un poco como
tú lo decías al inicio en tu
presentación Aquí hay una cosa y es que
de hecho algunos canales y medios lo
registraban así ya el mundo ha ido
superando poco a poco el tema covid y
China Parece ser que se quedó en el 2020
eso es lo que dicen de hecho algunos de
los protestantes y una de estas
cuestiones tiene que ver como también lo
decías con el tema de cero covid esa
política ha sido una política que es
digamos la estrategia del gobierno para
mostrar su digamos
mostrarse mejor que el resto de los
gobiernos del mundo y esa fue una
política que funcionó muy bien al
principio de la pandemia porque miraba
porcentualmente pues china pese al gran
número de habitantes que tiene logró
mantener las tasas de mortandad muy muy
bajas durante la pandemia sin embargo
qué pasa Ya dos años después el mundo
fue abriendo sus puertas y China sigue
con los confinamientos y el estallido
Porque todos estos movimientos digamos
todas estas protestas porque esto
todavía no se puede extrapolar a una
cosa mucho más grande todas estas
protestas tienen un detonante Cuál fue
el detonante aquí el detonante fue el
incendio que hubo en la ciudad de
durumchi de hecho en Shanghai se
concentran en la calle brunchy para
simbólicamente protestar contra esto que
dice mire este incendio provocó una diez
muertos y entre otras cosas estos
muertos no pudieron salir por las
medidas de confinamiento porque es que
además hay cosas que son bien
complicadas en el confinamiento chino
que quizás nosotros desconocemos hay
aplicaciones que te muestran tienen es
como un semáforo Y entonces aparece
verde cuando tú salir y aparece amarillo
cuando has tenido contacto con alguien
que ha tenido Kobe Y eso genera todo un
círculo para que te mantengan aislado y
esas medidas de confinamiento generan a
su vez otras cosas por ejemplo la gente
se queja de que no consigue comida la
gente se queja también de que por
ejemplo hace pocos días murió un bebé
porque la ambulancia no llegó a tiempo
por las medidas anticobida Entonces está
afectando la vida de las personas y hay
un malestar generalizado pero
evidentemente al ser una política
emblema del gobierno de chilling Pin que
además relanza diría yo utilizando un
término quizás no tan apropiado en el
momento del vigésimo Congreso pues
evidentemente termina afectando la
imagen porque es la política emblema
Pues en resumen Margarita le preguntó
ahora a nuestra invitada a Raquel algo
más para complementar de ese conjugación
de factores que se están mezclando en
China para llevar a estas
manifestaciones ciudadanas que llama la
atención del mundo occidental y bueno el
resto del planeta porque no es habitual
en China que los ciudadanos salgan a
manifestarse y sobre todo hacerles
reclamos directos a pedir por ejemplo la
renuncia del presidente chillimping y a
pedir que el gobierno comunista deje el
poder
sí Bueno aquí hay aspectos muy
interesantes a rescatar definitivamente
por ejemplo el desarrollo de este tipo
de aplicaciones que sean llamado el
crédito social dentro de China no es
algo nuevo o que de alguna forma parezca
en el contexto plenamente pandémico sino
que es algo que se venía de
desarrollando previo a este momento no
En ese sentido obviamente la política a
cero más la conjugación de este tipo de
créditos social vino a dar como violo
señalaba este Margarita un primer
momento en el cual pareciera ser
efectivo este tipo de de este de
políticas no sin embargo creo que hoy en
día es un punto muy interesante en Cómo
podemos observar a China en qué sentido
en el sentido de que varios de los temas
digamos sensibles dentro de la política
que el gobierno Chino este llama como
interna por ejemplo las situaciones de
regiones autónomas
situaciones por ejemplo de cómo se
inserta china en términos laborales
dentro de lo que son cadenas globales de
valor o incluso No ya este de la
libertad de expresión hoy en día como
una especie de Pequeños momentos que se
dan no solamente en la capital no sino
que llama muchísimo la atención como
bien señalaban el caso de el caso de El
caso por ejemplo de algunos otros este
manifestaciones tanto en Pekín como el
caso de Shanghai comienzan a hacer como
estos detonantes en temáticas en las
cuales Pues bueno hoy en día con el tema
de cómo se reafirma esta política del
cero a partir de lo que habían
mencionaban de la asamblea en octubre
cuestión que se esperaba que se relajara
de alguna forma Pues bueno detona este
tipo de temas este que están latentes no
que de alguna forma a nivel
internacional pues como bien lo decían
el gran desafío es Cómo entender algo
que de alguna forma pues se ha tratado
de mantener en este caso para que la
imagen de China al exterior sea una
buena imagen no y que de alguna manera
al interior comienzan a darse como estos
destellos a través de aplicaciones que
también están bañadas dentro de China la
imagen de China un tema que tengo para
analizar con ustedes dos Margaritas
Raquel continuó con Raquel para
preguntarle
en esta política de Cero en China que al
principio funcionó le sirvió Para
mitigar el impacto de la pandemia ya lo
decíamos ahí un poco de falta como de
sintonía con la realidad del resto de
del planeta que ya prácticamente volvió
a la normalidad qué tanto esto fue una
estrategia para combatir la pandemia de
Kobe 19 que resultó efectiva hasta un
punto pero también sirve como una
herramienta para tener más control sobre
los ciudadanos chinos y se está
camuflando con la excusa de los
confinamientos y de la pandemia Kobe 19
porque esto también va acompañado con un
problema de las vacunas si es que china
no ha querido comprar vacunas de otros
países para esta enorme población que
tiene garantizarle la vacunación y
depende de la producción local que no da
abasto por supuesto
Bueno si bien en este punto que señalas
este Santiago un aspecto importante es
como de alguna forma se ha construido
esta imagen de China al exterior como
proveedor de vacunas como de alguna
manera un país que toma cierta
responsabilidad con respecto a la
pandemia no obstante hay que mencionar
que si bien en la primera fase de la
pandemia definitivamente había una
justificación con respecto a este tipo
de restricciones de la política Cero en
función del desafío que es de alguna
forma contener un posible una posible
ola de contagio en el país con mayor
número de personas en el mundo no no
obstante en este sentido Ya hacia lo que
es el segundo el segundo momento de este
año y sobre todo en una coyuntura
política como lo fue la asamblea pasada
donde de alguna forma se rompe parte de
la historia política de china con el
tercer mandato de shegín de alguna forma
da pie no a de alguna manera a
cuestionarnos si realmente es una mera
intención en de salud o también lleva
algún otro tipo de Destello en función
de estabilidad política de alguna forma
de buscar otro tipo de legitimidad hacia
este tercer mandato por parte de en ese
sentido creo que hay un punto en donde
se comienza a rebasar la lógica o la
lectura en este caso de la estructura
más importante que es el partido que hay
que ponerlo muy muy bien sobre la sobre
la mesa que no es tanto la persona sino
en este caso la estructura que da
legitimidad a esa persona que es el
propio partido en donde la construcción
de la idea de lo que es lo colectivo
sigue siendo como que una lógica de ver
a un pueblo chino en términos de
bienestar pero es una lógica económica
más no en un bienestar a como lo tenemos
este en occidente Margarita por este
lado opinión esta estrategia de cobi 0
pero una herramienta de control yo creo
que aquí hay dos elementos que hay que
adicionar aparte de lo que ya decía
Raquel y es por un lado evidentemente y
en el discurso lo dejó claro y hace un
año lo dejó claro
sea la manera como reaccionemos y
manejemos el covid va a ser la manera en
la que nos vamos vamos a ser juzgados
Entonces es una política de estrategia
del prestigio para el partido yo me
atrevería a decir que claro Aunque la
estructura es una estructura colegiada
así sea un solo para el partido único el
partido comunista dentro del partido
comunista y diferentes posturas pero en
el caso de lo que vimos en el vigésimo
congreso y lo que hemos estado viendo
ahora es que cada vez más se acaban esas
diferentes posturas Y tenemos a chilling
Pin y a sus aliados apostándole mucho a
esa estrategia del prestigio que al
igual que la misma política de covid 0
ha tenido un efecto negativo y eso está
relacionado con lo que ustedes están
diciendo el primer punto a nivel interno
tiene que ver claro estamos viendo un
sistema que son 1400 millones de
personas pero con un panotismo que logra
una vigilancia estricta el crédito que
del que nos hablaba Raquel público pero
una gente que se está cansando porque
claro es una nueva genera Y como te
decía Una cosa es el confinamiento que
tuvimos Durante los primeras etapas para
para disminuir muertes pero es que en
este momento esto ha tenido un efecto
Boomerang en China y es que no tienen no
tienen inmunidad de rebaño porque cuando
llegaron las nuevas cepas Entonces ellos
no tienen digamos resistencias naturales
a esas nuevas cepas y estamos en este
momento viviendo los picos más altos de
contagios de Kobe entonces aparece un
contagio de covid masivo digámoslo así
en una ciudad y cierran toda la ciudad
Entonces por ejemplo los trabajadores de
Fox coma hace poco muchos tuvieron que
salir y dejar sus trabajos y recontratar
un personal porque no puede acabar la
cadena de producción de la que Raquel
hablaba entonces ambas cosas están
teniendo un efecto negativo tanto en el
partido comunista como en chiquinpín
como en la política de cero covid porque
no han podido disminuir el nivel de
contagios muerte Sí pero el nivel de
contagios no Entonces yo me atrevería a
decir que claro no puede uno especular
tampoco de si hay una estrategia para
controlar aún más la población porque
creo que China tiene un suficiente
control sobre su población en este
momento Entonces sería como eso lo que
habría que Añadir a lo que dijo Raquel
tenemos entonces aquí tres aspectos ya
hemos analizado esa política de cero
vemos que hay claramente un sector de la
población que no está de acuerdo con con
el manejo que se le está dando en este
momento al tema de el covid 19 en su
momento funcionó pero aquí hay dos
elementos que quiero analizar y es usted
mencionar la imagen como es la imagen
entonces de chilling Pin ahora después
de ser reelecto para ese histórico
tercer mandato que es rompe todas las
tradiciones del partido comunista y
también como es la imagen del partido
comunista que también ha dejado de lado
algunos sectores que eran muy
tradicionales al interior del partido y
que ahora se ven un poco dejados de lado
por ese clan que se armó alrededor de
chilling Pin bueno por un lado yo diría
que estoy que analizarlo también
teniendo en cuenta que siempre hemos
hablado de que existen dos chinas
Existen dos chinas porque hay una china
que es urbana ya no hay una china que es
era china rural Entonces cuando uno ve
estas protestas y cuando hablamos de los
masivo de estas protestas hay que
matizar también esa afirmación
básicamente por qué porque nosotros en
las protestas vemos
jóvenes urbanos
digamos que están ven en sus en su
cotidianidad una afectación mucho mayor
con todos estos temas en el cuando uno
se va hacia las zonas Rurales Pues
básicamente la gente está de acuerdo con
esas con esa política es difícil saber
cuál es la percepción real que hay en
China con respecto a chilling pin porque
evidentemente a pesar de que nos dicen
que se puede protestar Fíjate que un
símbolo maravilloso que además es
copiado de las protestas de Hong Kong
que ahora le han puesto como siempre
bautizamos estas propuestas protestas en
la cuatro no porque es la Hoja en blanco
una hoja en blanco que muestra si yo
muestro una hoja en blanco en una
protesta eso dice mucho más que
cualquier eslogan o cosa que yo pueda
pedir dentro de esa protesta Entonces yo
creo que la imagen de sí está afectada
esto es una percepción no lo podría
decir digamos de manera concreta no y y
sobre todo porque tú lo veías antes el
congreso ese vigésimo congreso es una
puesta en escena maravillosa que nos
muestra todo un despliegue y aquí
veíamos que la gente pasaba por el
frente de los televisores y a veces ni
siquiera se paraba mirar el tema
Entonces yo creo que ahí hay ahí hay un
proceso donde ya han pasado varias
generaciones a pesar de los controles
estas generaciones son mucho más activas
piden otras cosas claro y y ya el
partido se ha ido quedando cada vez más
obsoleto en eso y falta esa sintonía
entre partido y ciudadanos y todo hay
que decirlo las protestas se han
concentrado en las grandes ciudades
chinas no solamente Beijing Shanghai que
son pues prácticamente los centros
urbanos más grandes pero es que en China
una ciudad normal tiene cuatro o cinco
millones de habitantes un poco más de
una ciudad promedio han sido las
ciudades donde hay polos industriales
importantes llama la atención esas
manifestaciones en es una ciudad
completamente al otro lado del país en
el oeste cerca a la frontera con
kirguistánicas y que tiene una realidad
muy distinta la del resto del país pasó
a preguntarle a Raquel Cuál es su
percepción entonces de la imagen de de
el presidente chilling ping que está
comenzando este tercer mandato y le está
costando comenzarlo
y bueno dando un poco continuidad a lo
que mencionaba Margarita un punto
interesante es que cuando en el 2018
casualmente se hace esta reforma para
que pueda lograr un tercer mandato o el
mandato indefinido en con la reforma
constitucional es curioso porque varios
del de las reacciones digamos mediáticas
a través de principalmente redes
sociales fue que muchísimos de estos
nuevas generaciones de personas chinas
comenzaron no a cuestionar la intención
de del poder mantener a una persona
dentro de la estructura este política de
China no Entonces en ese sentido digo no
es una casualidad que hoy en día también
por ejemplo estudiantes dentro de
universidades emblemáticas en la
historia china como es el caso de se
entren en esta dinámica de las
manifestaciones no y que bien como bien
lo decían también se vuelve como una un
movimiento mediático con un simbolismo
una semiótica muy importante a nivel
internacional
que si bien en esta cuestión de la
Muralla es cibernética que hoy en día es
china el hecho de que salgan este tipo
de imágenes este al exterior con esta
emblema como bien lo mencionaban de de
la cuatro este con respecto al tema de
la libertad de expresión juego un punto
muy interesante no en este caso es ver
este proceso evolutivo de cómo previo a
a este momento incluso a la pandemia de
alguna manera el famoso sueño chino que
pareciera ser que era como el elemento
que había legitimado y un tanto
balanceado la realidad del oeste con el
este de China pues hoy en día comienza a
tener estos cuestionamientos como lo
mencionaba un poco este por encima al
principio del programa de cómo hoy en
día ya no solamente es el tener el
dinero no este esta posibilidad del del
mundo capitalista que les da el partido
comunista sino también comenzar a
reflexionar sobre otro tipo de de
realidades y libertades que de alguna
forma fuera de China se perciben no y
que en este caso algo muy importante El
problema del ciberactivismo que pese a
esta muralla Pues bueno comienza a dar
como estos destellos también al interior
de china con esta nueva generación de
personas Raquel Quiero que profundicemos
en ese tema La censura de los medios
sigue siendo latente lo veíamos al
inicio del programa ponía algunos
ejemplos al azar simplemente algunos
medios chinos que no han mencionado el
tema de las manifestaciones restándole
un poco importancia a este malestar
ciudadano pero pero vemos cada vez usted
lo dice esta muralla se está rompiendo
un poco desde adentro cada vez más
jóvenes chinos acceden a aplicaciones
occidentales
para poder difundir lo que está pasando
allí o por lo menos dar a conocer su
sentir en torno al gobierno obviamente
esto es aprovechado por los detractores
de china en occidente que se están
frotando las manos viendo pues como este
país tiene una inestabilidad que no es
otro problema que no haya tenido otro
país en occidente que no son
manifestaciones que no haya tenido
cualquier otro país en el mundo pero
como es china pues obviamente se le da
relevancia
Sí claro y de alguna manera esto que
bien mencionas también tiene que ver
muchísimo con el momento no el momento
político del que viene china nada donde
pareciera ser que viene un líder que ha
buscado de alguna manera este unificar
entre comillas el tema del partido de
quién es su gabinete y que el hecho de
que se vea este tipo de manifestaciones
pues obviamente pone en cuestión no
realmente el grado de legitimidad En ese
sentido Este creo que hay un punto muy
interesante en el cual por ejemplo ahora
que al principio del programa se
mostraban estos medios incluso
incluyendo lo que es global Times que es
más como de esta perspectiva
internacional No sé no se da importancia
no Incluso el la temática sanitaria se
enfoca a promover las campañas de
vacunación en ciertas poblaciones dentro
de todo lo que hace han ido desplegado
hoy no entonces en esta parte Obviamente
el tema de la libertad de expresión
dentro de China pues está siendo parte
de del cuestionamiento no no solamente
en la sociedad china sino también el
papel que juegan los medios extranjeros
dentro de China por obviamente los este
pues restricciones no que existen
incluso la manera en Cómo operan y
tienen estos permisos para poder emitir
noticias a nivel internacional y que un
punto interesante que se hablaba era
como el hecho del mundial no se está
transmitiendo dentro de China para no
dar esta imagen dentro de China de cómo
funciona el el mundo sin el covid sí que
muestran las personas en las gradas de
los estadios sin llevar mascarilla Y eso
el gobierno chino piensa que le manda un
mensaje equivocado a los ciudadanos
Margarita por este lado opinión sobre el
tema de la censura y la extiendo un poco
más la pregunta sobre esa detención del
periodista de la bbc que estaba
cubriendo una de estas manifestaciones
también obviamente occidente aprovechó
esta oportunidad para
reclamarle muchísimo el tema de la
censura y la libertad de expresión a
China evidentemente digamos esto es un
revés para el tema del gobierno porque
el gobierno ha intentado Mostrar que esa
política de es la política emblema como
lo he venido diciendo Pero además que la
gente se siente orgulloso de eso que la
gente se sienta orgullosa de que han
sido un país con un muy buen manejo de
la pandemia gracias a su líder pero
nosotros ya vimos que en Shanghai y el
confinamiento de casi dos meses generó
unos impactos en la población entonces
Claro en este sentido evidentemente no
es nada nuevo en China en China ha
habido protestas De hecho hace algunas
semanas hubo en Pekín algunas protestas
con respecto a esto mismo lo que pasa es
que esta se extendieron un poco más pero
lo que hay que decir es que la política
de la censura en China la política
Además del control de lo que consumen
los jóvenes en China ha sido constante
durante todo este tiempo entre otras
cosas porque dentro de ese sueño chino
que mencionaba Raquel hay una parte que
es que los jóvenes tienen que llevar y
promocionar su cultura y tienen que ser
unos emblemas de la cultura china y para
ello no pueden estar contaminados con
esos elementos de la cultura dental para
aquellos puedan ser esa imagen de china
en el mundo Entonces claro este tipo de
contradicciones que esto es un malestar
social evidentemente que siempre se va a
entre mezclar por la realidad con un
elemento político pero yo no diría que
esto que salgan dos o tres voces a decir
que dimita chillín no quiere decir que
el gobierno de chilling piensa este
tambaleando en este momento ni mucho
menos Creo que a veces se
sobredimensiona un poco por este afán
que tiene occidente pero creo que sí
está afectando O sea si hay una
afectación real para el gobierno chino
en toda esta hora con respecto al trato
de los periodistas pues ya como lo
veíamos ellos salen a lavar un poco la
imagen y decir No es que a los que por
ejemplo con algunos de los protestantes
que encarcelaron fijaros que no se
identificó como debía es que no pudo no
pudo explicar que era lo que estaba
haciendo y con el con el periodista de
la bbc fue un poco lo mismo No pero
realmente es una censura de ustedes
tienen que hacer su trabajo y su trabajo
es como lo dicen en las dictaduras no
cruce la línea roja Uno nunca sabe cuál
es la línea roja que no pueden cruzar en
el tema de libertad de expresión porque
es bien en vivo me gusta que hagas
aclaración Margarita que cuando hablamos
que hay un reclamo para que salga chuyin
pino O salga el gobierno comunista del
poder esto no quiere decir que se esté
tambaleando ni se está cayendo a pedazos
sino que llama la atención que pocas
veces se hace ese tipo de reclamos y ese
tipo de pedidos directamente pidiendo la
salida del gobierno y del partido por
eso llama la atención Pero esto es una
estructura muy sólida que costaría
muchísimo llevar y quizás lo nuevo si es
muy interesante porque eso es algo nuevo
lo que decía la profesora Raquel con
respecto a que se están involucrando
unos sectores de la población bien
interesantes como son los estudiantes de
las universidades entonces a veces la
gente quiere evocar Diana menos con todo
esto he visto algunos que van un poco
más allá y quieren pero pero me parece
que si hay un cambio necesario en la
política de cero covid si tienen que
mejorar porque a largo plazo si podría
agrandarse el asunto un poco yo hacía
una relación entre dos tipos de
protestas que en sus fundamentos y sus
sentir son completamente distintas las
protestas que están teniendo lugar en
Irán y las protestas que vemos en China
el origen es completamente distinto Pero
hay un punto en común por lo menos yo se
lo encuentro así ustedes a ver qué
piensan y es simplemente este hartazgo
por estos gobiernos tan completamente
vigilantes rigurosos con su con sus
leyes y que captan un poco las las las
libertades de los ciudadanos esto Qué
mensaje le manda al mundo y a esos otros
gobiernos similares que manejan a sus
poblaciones con fundamentos parecidos
que piensa Raquel
bueno en este sentido creo que el punto
que se vuelve atractivo para hacer esta
comparativa es lo que bien señalabas el
tipo de régimen no que de alguna forma
catalogado desde occidente son regímenes
no totalmente democráticos digo a pesar
de que se puedan asumir estos mismos
este gobiernos como democráticos digo
china lo hace como una democracia
consultiva si es como yo se asumen Pero
el punto interesante Creo que este
insisto en Cómo hoy en día el tema de
cómo poder tener acceso a la información
a través de redes sociales o el papel
que a partir de la pandemia las redes
sociales han tenido han generado este
tipo de situación o en el caso por
ejemplo de Irán y el caso de de China
Pues el ingrediente de estos valores
políticos se vuelve todavía muchísimo
más atractivo no sin embargo no hay que
verlo como una cuestión totalmente ajena
No Incluso en América Latina lo podemos
ver este que es parte del pan de cada
día el hecho de tener este tipo de harta
redes sociales no a lo mejor nosotros de
las mismas temáticas que estas
sociedades en otras latitudes tienen
pero que definitivamente hablan
muchísimo de cómo yo no llamaría una
cuestión de que sea una cuestión de ser
democrático o no democrático sino como
hoy en día la realidad pues pandémicas Y
es que estamos entrando realmente a esta
fase las instituciones comienzan a no
adaptarse tan rápidamente a como son las
demandas de la sociedad a nivel global
claro y yo tengo que aclarar acá una
cosa en orden tratando de hacer un poco
de balance es que todo este análisis lo
estamos haciendo desde la perspectiva
occidental no somos ciudadanos chinos no
somos iraníes no estamos allí en la
realidad conocemos
lo que vemos a través de los medios de
comunicación ustedes son expertas en el
tema por los estudios que han hecho pero
no somos ciudadanos de ese país como
para poder hacer un análisis desde otro
punto de vista lo tenemos que hacer
desde la realidad de nosotros el mundo
occidental eso puede que genere un poco
desbalance en el análisis pero es lo que
tenemos es lo que hay aquí para hacer
Margarita de hecho yo iba compartir mi
mi posición desde ese punto quizás hay
una cosa en común en ambas porque yo
diría que no se puede compararlo
incomparable pero si hay un punto en
común en ambos casos Fíjate que China la
República Popular de China surge a
partir de la revolución de Mao que gana
en 1949 el Irán que conocemos hoy es el
Irán que surge gracias a la yatola
hotmaine en 1979 y establece una
teocracia en ambos casos ellos se están
poniendo un muro una diferencia abismal
entre ellos y nosotros o sea accidentes
esto y nosotros somos esto en los dos
casos con sus particularidades sus
características y yo me atrevería a
decir que son como una suerte de
autocracias con prácticas democráticas
en los dos casos que tienen en común
digamos además de la lectura que
nosotros hacemos desde esta perspectiva
de ellos son diferentes no entonces son
diferentes están protestando y quieren
ser como nosotros allí yo me atrevería a
decir eso hay que matizarlo mucho claro
porque es que yo el malestar social en
todo digamos en la sociedad en general
se deriva de unos aspectos similares lo
que nosotros estamos viendo en términos
de protestas lo empezamos a ver desde
las revoluciones de colores en el 2000
con las repúblicas soviéticas luego se
extendió a la primavera árabe y luego
vino a latinoamérica Y tuvo un momento
de quietud con el Coby pero el covid
profundizó algunos de los elementos
diferenciadores y por ejemplo de brechas
económicas las sanciones en Irán han
afectado muchísimo a la población y
todos empiezan entre mezclar Y entonces
hay un detonante la crítica contra china
en realidad nunca ha sido el tema
económico los niveles de crecimiento en
China son altos pero claro una claro una
de las cosas es que dicen volvemos a lo
que decíamos hay dos chinas no no todos
se benefician igual y el covid en China
no es ajeno a esto a profundizado
algunos de esos elementos y yo creo ese
factor económico también está generando
que estas protestas tengan ahora ese
componente un temor que existe y que es
real de cómo impacta esto y además
todavía no ha impactado la cadena de
producción internacional como decía
Raquel que hablaba de todo esto pero eso
a eso se va a llegar Claro claro para
Navidad de teléfonos móviles y
artefactos de tecnología Pues porque es
que la interrupción de la vida cotidiana
de los chinos ha afectado completamente
las grandes y pequeñas empresas afecta
la economía china afecta la imagen de
China y eso genera un efecto bola de
nieve en el mundo por los productos
iPhone dijo que ya no iba a cumplir con
las expectativas por el tema de las de
esta fábrica Entonces yo diría que
también nosotros tenemos que empezar a
hacer unas lecturas mucho más complejas
me queda un minuto para la para el
cierre del programa Raquel rápidamente
una conclusión estas manifestaciones A
dónde nos van a llevar qué escenario
vamos a ver en las próximas semanas creo
que lo más interesante es ver de alguna
manera Cómo se preparan este tipo de
restricciones por parte del gobierno
hace un momento coyuntural en China que
es el festejo del año nuevo chino no O
sea el hecho de cómo va a reaccionar la
sociedad en un momento cumbre en el cual
al inicio de la pandemia Pues fue como
que el punto en el cual se dio un cambio
total dentro de China y que creo que en
este sentido esa parte va a determinar
si Se incrementa o no este hartazgo
Claro porque es el momento en el que la
mayor cantidad de ciudadanos chinos se
desplazan a sus diferentes regiones para
esta celebración que es sumamente
importante para ellos Margarita
conclusión Para encerrar rápidamente
pues yo me atrevería a decir que china
va a tener que empezar a ceder en su
política de Cero covid y porque si no
las manifestaciones van a continuar y
esto podría ser un reto para el gobierno
de lo que él quiere consolidar en este
momento internacionalmente su imagen
internacional que eso también tiene un
peso así no lo no sea digamos lo
principal para Un gobierno pero la
imagen internacional de China y cómo se
proyecta El mundo es importante Pues a
Margarita Raquel les agradezco muchísimo
por este análisis para la audiencia de
France 24 panel femenino de primerísimo
nivel hoy en el programa para analizar
este tema En nombre del equipo técnico
Les agradecemos la sintonía de la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Keila maestre y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Lina Guzmán
ustedes pueden seguir en sintonía de
France 24